I don't think that the we are strange
falafel countries in the center of
Europe you've seen massive
demonstrations protests demonstrations
up to the Prime Minister to decide
whether he wants her to step aside and
I'm believe in the independence of
Algeria Shuri
with time running out for Brussels and
London to get a brexit deal the EU is
planning to heap all the blame on
Britain if the negotiations fail my
guest this week here in Prague is the
Czech foreign minister Tomas Petra check
he has surprisingly clear differences
with the government he serves so why
doesn't he resign
[Music]
tell my spectra check
welcome to complex on thank you much
just a few days before Britain is due to
leave the European Union Boris Johnson
says he wants deal do you trust him I
think that the all options are still
possible for assets you don't answer the
question do you trust it it's a little
time to find an agreement we are in the
situation but there is a turbulent
development in in UK there are some
proposals on table but time for
negotiation is limited I notice you
don't say you do trust him you're
forgoing that option Boris Johnson said
that he is willing to leave UK if you
knew without agreement and for us this
is not a good option but if UK is not
able to find a compromise and have a
majority in the parliament for agreement
I don't see any option it's now clear
that if there's no deal there's likely
to be considerable damage not just to
Britain but to the EU economies as well
why do you sit in silence waiting for
this slow-motion car crash to happen
without making your opinion felt and
easing the path to a deal because a deal
is in your interest we we have been
quite vocal that we want a deal
but the ball is on the British side at
the moment but it never just on one side
is it but we have negotiated for number
of months so for more than a year about
an agreement which was how to find a
compromise on 27 side as well and now we
are dealing with the situation that one
side was negotiating without clear
support for outcome the negotiation and
the ball is really on the on the British
side we would like to see what are they
proposals especially when it comes to
backstop because so this is the main
challenge for us you talked about
divisions among the eu27 it was
difficult to get
unified line here Brussels always says
you're absolutely in unity on the issue
it's that's not true is it it is true it
it was necessary to accommodate concerns
of many member states before we reached
the agreement last year
and it was not an easy task for you a
negotiator is also to accommodate an
interest and concerns of our member
states like I want but many others well
you have for instance you have shared
Michele who's the new european council
president he he wants he says that no
deal is better than a bad deal you have
a Silla fund Allah who's going to be the
new commission president she wants to
extend the deadline for Britain so she
would be willing to extend the article
50 negotiators so you do have divisions
here you have division minor one maybe
that's a model is it but for us for us
is also important that if UK wants to
extend the period for unag oshi ations
and that there are good reasons for that
presented by by Westminster let's let's
consider it are you content to blame
Britain put all the blame on Britain if
the negotiations fail because that's
what Brussels is leading towards that's
what jean-claude Juncker has already
said if things fail it'll be the british
british fault do you chefs i would blame
for this first of all I think that the
blame game is something that is not
contributing to good faith negotiation a
peptide that our sauce is playing and
the game has been there let's try to
limit the damage that has been already
caused by a blame game
it is not blind one side or one side
only I think that for for the steak of
that women I think that we should be
open for the proposal from the other
side let's discuss it within eu27 but
it's important to keep the unity in the
European Union that's something that we
have strive for we have been able to
maintain the unity over the past year
and it's important also to be prepared
for
establishing relations between the block
and UK after the exit happened European
industry European industry is very
nervous getting nervous as we get down
to the deadline also the citizens we
have around a hundred thousand people
check people living in UK and so far
they really don't know what's going to
happen they live in uncertainty and he's
also not a very positive part of the
whole process common features are
warning about a seismic shift in trading
conditions if he leaves with no deal and
many of the changes have a big car
manufacturer in Europe we are also
concerned about the impact that's why we
always supported a agreement reducer
that provide us a space to negotiate
future relations between EU and UK
including a trade relations between the
block and of Great Britain without the
result the agreement we will get to the
situation that UK becomes a third
country from one moment to another
harming the relations causing a lot of
problems to not only car manufacturers
but for many other industries I
understand what you say you mentioned
the Irish back stock which is the main
stumbling block to getting an agreement
are you happy that this one issue could
torpedo the whole deal between Britain
and the EU it should really worth
Brussels digging in its heels on this
one but we should have a provision a
whole deal we should keep in mind the
whole history of the island that is not
possible to divide for them Ireland at
the same time we need to make sure that
we protect internal market and the best
ever and what we've done the Good Friday
Agreement we are trying to to preserve
the both and the backstop is a way how
to preserve both we don't want to return
back before great big Friday agreement
but if there's no deal you will jump the
Good Friday of you we also UK come up
come up comes up with some proposals
there are some if it doesn't
we'll put up aborted the EU will put up
a border it's already said it would if
there is a No Deal there will be a
brother's that's why we also would like
to see that UK come UK comes up with
some proposals there are some currently
discussed and negotiated we are open to
negotiations but these things if things
go badly are you seriously telling me
that it's worth risking a return to the
terrible violence that took place in
Northern Ireland simply to preserve the
backstop is not because of only
protecting the single market is also a
way to preserve that is most important
it is also preserve the be Friday
Agreement mr. Petri check you in the
Czech Republic you have your own
problems with the EU don't you your part
of the visit Guard group which is known
as the kind of awkward squad with Poland
Hungary and Slovakia
you don't like quotas for irregular
migrants you don't like the climate
change policies you refuse to sign up to
the EU's 2050s zero-carbon go why I
don't think that we are strange clump of
countries in the center of Europe first
of all we are very active in your
opinion on many issues why did you
refuse to sign up to the climate go the
20 still negotiated we are we are ever
about the need to have a strong climate
and energy policies within the European
Union we are meeting our obligations
when it comes to policy agreement at the
same time what we want to have a
comprehensive approach to the industry I
say Europe to see that the reality your
promise to publish has said you is also
on may less than 10 at 1/10 of the
global emissions you is not going to
salvage the whole climate without others
and that's a that's a you in this
computer crime Minister mr. babish has
said why should we decide 31
years ahead of time what will happen in
2050 that's not a very helpful comment
because if we don't decide now 2050 is
going to look very different than it
might otherwise do and I agree that it
is time to start policies that will have
impact until your Prime Minister's I
agree that we need a stronger policies
in this era he does at the same time we
would like to have a rational realistic
debate who's going to get their way the
Prime Minister are you in on this but
Prime Minister is also part of the
negotiations we are taking part of the
solution decisions now he says why
should we take decisions 31 years ahead
he discussed was a new president of the
European Commission about the climate
change with other partners in the Europe
he probably presented the position of my
country that as industrial experimental
country we would like to see that all
the options the town table will not lead
to the industrialization lots of jobs we
don't have we don't want to have a
jobless future on migration as far as
the EU is concerned you've been equally
unhelpful when it came to taking a share
of the huge numbers of irregular
migrants turning up at the EU borders
you decided this wasn't for you in 2017
you took just 12 of them out of an EU
mandated quota of 2,700 not 1,200 you
took just 12 and then your government
said it wouldn't no longer comply just
like hungry and just like Poland why why
won't you help yeah hoping you take the
money from the EU you don't play by the
rules of the e and we are giving a lot
of money to prevent migration to solve
some of the problems in the countries of
origin or in a lot of money 100 million
crowns it's a it's a hundreds of
millions and it's a computer resources
available which is under 4 million euros
a year no it's a it's much more money
like we are now preparing a project with
Germany
Morocco we have project is vitally in
Libya we are annually giving hundreds of
millions of Czech crowns to Middle East
North Africa we have just because it's
resulted in helping the Libyan Coast
Guard take people back to Libya and put
them in unacceptable conditions
incarcerated in camps indefinitely being
beaten up and sexually abused and that's
thanks to the European Union's policies
we use accompli think you're doing some
good yeah yeah we have a very
complicated situation in Libya and
largely to the fact that it is an
astable internally divided country in
conflict and international community has
very limited scope how to operate in the
country how to provide assistance to
refugees there at the same time there
are many other where we have been
successful and that's a possible
situation in Middle East where we have
been able to assist the refugees in
Jordan in Lebanon we have been able to
assist internally displaced people in
cities in Syria as well you plan to York
in Mali don't you we are we are also
strengthening this is a country with an
appalling human rights record last year
they were accused by the human right by
Human Rights Watch of committing
atrocities that's the army in Mali this
is the government you're going to help
now we are going to help the people and
how is the money to get there directly
or through the government we are first
of all helping through the European
mission there you would like to
contribute the first go through the
government whose human rights record is
pretty questionable we are not
allocating any France directly for the
government we would like to work with
the people of his local communities we
would like to work through international
organizations that are trying to
stabilize the people that are affected
by internal conflict in Mali as well and
we are also trying to help help the
local to get basic security that's
something that people really need this
is country report
Freedom House said asylum seekers to
your country are routinely detained and
conditions and conditions in detention
centers are generally poor why why do
you keep doing four conditions the
questions probably for the Ministry of
Interior
I'm government I haven't done any any
steps in an acident process the country
has been the destination for many atoms
peace secrets were in the past
especially from the east what's the
clear there are not only movement from
the south from the from Africa or from
Middle East but dozens of thousand
people coming to the opinion from the
east from Eastern Europe from Asia and
only at last year we had 30,000 Nuka
incoming people from countries like pray
in Mongolia century a century year so
that's also focus not only on one one
flow there are outflows and in this
regard we are trying to have a regulated
process through which we can allow
people to get in freedom has also
reported that xenophobic and
anti-refugee rhetoric had been voiced by
your Prime Minister
babish and your president Miller Zaman
how helpful is that it is not helpful
helpful I think that we need to fight
any forms of kind of phobia is coming
from senior members of your government
in 2011 before becoming president mr.
Sammon labeled Islam and tea
civilization and said there were no such
thing as a moderate Muslim just like
there were no moderate Nazis that's
that's that's quite a hateful comment
isn't i'm a social democrat i am made
and for me any kind of intolerance sena
phobia anti-semitism is a big problem
but it is not the case of my country
only we have witnessed this trend across
European Union and we need to have a
strategy how to fight it that's why I'm
so glad that I'm in the government Here
I am
the era of raava is is now a
commissioner
we'll have this in a portfolio that we
will take initiative on that under issue
the rise of xenophobia racism
anti-semitism is a problem of European
officials are you fighting you have a
lot of guy a lot of we have but let's be
honest there's a problem of my country
only that's my name is you have foreign
minister of this country and I'm I'm
debating to you about the Czech Republic
and I'm not advocating this this kind of
rhetoric for me it is not acceptable as
also sure Democrat I believe that
politicians should give an example to to
people that we can work together on a
better future on addressing the fears
that are within the population than
people without using this kind of
rhetoric we talked about the climate
issues we talked about the migration
another cause of tension with the EU is
allegations that your billionaire Prime
Minister mr. babish improperly received
more than 17 million euros in EU
subsidies to the AG referred business
with which he has been both directly and
indirectly connected and EU audit
alleged significant conflicts of
interest in his private business
although he said he doesn't think he's
done anything wrong and he called the EU
report an attack on the Czech Republic
do you see that report as an attack on
the Czech Republic out of notice is an
attack on the country I think that we
should leave it to investigators to come
up with final final findings we we have
ministries responsible I have provided
the information the European Commission
asked for I believe that everybody
should be considered considered that the
crowd and I think why it happened
until it is proved it is damaging to
your relations with the EU isn't it I
haven't been I haven't witnessed that uh
any of my colleagues ask what what's
happening many
you is blood not backing down on the
charges despite the time denials from
the prime minister but the investigation
is still ongoing investigation into the
u.s. my position clear but but one case
has been closed recently by the
prosecutors we are now providing
information to Europe including
Commission when it comes to the audits
or itself talking about the domestic
charges that were to be about domestic
charges related to the executed rot at
the same time the European Commission is
still continuing these delicious's is
refusing to let payments go from the EU
budget until the fine-structure yeah the
final report is presented and the final
report hasn't been presented yet when
the proud prosecutor dropped the case
against mr. babish he published an
explanation of his decision half of it
was blacked out what has he got to hide
and what has the government got to hide
with this why do you offer the
explanation to the public and you black
half of it out what's the point of that
because there is a superior prosecutor
still analyzing the outcome of this
about this I believe in Independence of
our judiciary I don't have any reason to
question it you're not suspicious and at
the moment the superior to the
prosecutor is now studying the files and
should come up whether he is going to
reconsider the decision or not but I
think that it is up to prosecution an
independent persecution should have a
time to decide through their internal
processes about the case you're not
suspicious that two weeks after the
police recommended charges this is this
is something some this is a public
information until it is it is finally
decided it is still a part of the
judiciary process in Germany you don't
you don't publish the
before they are closed this has been put
out in the press these accusations one
accusations after another do you not
think it's time that the prime minister
who has denied all the accusations
against him would step aside to clear
his name because this is taking up a lot
of government time and you've seen
massive demonstrations protests
demonstrations against this in the
capital biggest demonstrations here in
Prague for 30 years this is up to the
Prime Minister to decide whether he
wants her to step aside onto your
opinion that's member of the junior
partner in the coalition what's your
social democracy I saw several times
said that it would be the best way if I
know come up with with somebody who can
take the position until Prime Minister's
is so easily to step down no I think
this is a question for the for the party
for our coalition partner not for us to
decide but you have senior member of the
junior but we are not commenting on
personal policies of our coalition
partners the head of the OTS opposition
party the largest opposition group said
he respected the prosecutors decision
not to press charges but said the whole
case leaves behind a bad taste and a
divided society you you're nodding you
agree with that do you okay leaves that
agree that it leaves bad taste but as I
said I believe that our judiciary paper
signatures are fully independent and if
they come up with some decision that is
outcome of independent inquiry the
influential Financial Times said the
conflicts between mr. babish is
extensive businesses and his role as
Prime Minister are a stain on Czech
democracy just as Silvio Berlusconi
tarnished it in his reputation two
decades ago I wonder how long you are
prepared to sit in this coalition and
have this stain unchecked democracy how
long do you not get to a point where you
consider your position though but and
then you have many rankings were our
situation has improved over the past
year
so really we have improve on Rooivalk
and corruption
not according to greco you haven't which
is the Council of Europe's
anti-corruption body only built at all
on the country give you some
recommendations and said you haven't
exempted any of them in many in many
areas there has been confirmed progress
we have started implementing
anti-corruption strategy adopted in 2018
let me echo CID your country's reliance
procedure Minister non compliance
procedure but these procedures have to
take time to to comply with some of them
and we also cross permanently applying
our policy display and there has been
referred to international international
community but I want to go back to the
question at what point do you consider
your position and say I can no longer
serve in this government because I
disagree with what's going on disagree
with what the prime minister says the
president says president went back on
her word and said he had previously said
he would never stop an investigation
into mr. published he changed his mind
and said yeah this is quite possible the
speculation about what's going to happen
after this is what he said that it's not
how can you slice it into says that his
word it's a directly elected president
and that's up to the people to decide in
an election that personal decision and
what about team what about a sign what
about and was the alternative them to
come to stay in opposition outside the
government and I know government we will
have what would you have well what would
it be you answer that question you ask
the question it will be government
supported by a populist and extremist
forces and certainly not in the interest
of my country that's why we provide bird
the cost of this coalition at the same
time as a social democracy we need to
maintain and keep the independence of
judiciary we need to be the Guardian so
it's going to be a fight with these
charges isn't it all these charges are
done
as I'm saying that we need to play the
role of keepers and that our task in the
government I believe and still there
hasn't been any final decision on any of
the cases we are waiting for the for the
outcome of the Commission's inquiry we
are also waiting for the domestic cases
to be finally closed until that we are
in the realm of speculations which
relieves a lot of bad taste I fully
understand that there are a lot of good
judgment
at the same time democracy in a country
that respects rule of law you expect to
wait until the court decides Thomas
Patrick
thank you very much for being
comfortable
[Music]
you
[Music]